hi guys i'm raul from simply learn and
today i'd like to welcome all of you to
this training video on azure let's ask
the question
what is microsoft azure microsoft azure
is actually a cloud service platform
that allows users to build
manage scale and deploy applications by
giving them access to cloud services
now these cloud services range from
creating virtual machines to creating
functions that run themselves without
having to worry about hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet
now here are some things that you need
to know about azure firstly it was
launched on the 1st of february 2010.
it has data centers in more than 42
regions across the world
they also say that 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions
next azure is preferred by 80 of the
fortune 500 companies which means that
the best of the best in the market
only choose to work with azure and
finally azure is the second largest
cloud service provider
in the market right now let's talk about
azure services
as i told you azure provides services
for a wide range of domains
now let's have a look at some of these
domains there's ai and machine learning
compute containers database identity
management tools networking security
storage and so much more now let's have
a look at some of the individual
services within these domains
firstly you have azure virtual machines
with azure virtual machines what you get
is the opportunity to create windows or
linux virtual machines
now all of this is possible in a matter
of seconds with a large amount of
customization
now let's have a look at some of its
features firstly you can choose from a
wide variety of virtual machine options
then you have a large amount of
optimization available to you for
example
what size of operating system do you
want how much size do you want allocated
to it
what version of the system is it and so
much more
then it provides low cost and permanent
billing now azure provides you permanent
billing which means
that you're only charged for how much
time you use the service
and finally you have enhanced security
and protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have a platform
which enables you to create micro
services now this also makes the process
of application lifecycle management a
whole lot
easier as a direct result you can create
applications with a faster time to
market
it supports windows linux on-premises or
other clouds
and it enables you to do a tremendous
amount of scaling up
depending on your requirement and
finally we have functions
now with functions you can build
applications with the help of serverless
computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used
you can create applications in any
language that you want
and the only thing you need to worry
about is the code of the application
everything other than that that is the
hardware requirements are taken care of
by azure
now let's have a look at the networking
services firstly we have the azure cdn
or the content delivery network
with azure cdn what you get is the
ability to deliver your content with
reduced load times fast responsiveness
and less bandwidth now cdn can be
integrated with several other azure
services
so that the process can move at a faster
rate it can handle heavy loads
and traffic spikes with ease it also
provides a robust
security system now with the content
that's delivered you can get advanced
analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers
are using your content next we have
express route
with express route you can connect your
on-premises network
to azure through a private network now
by default
this lowers latency it increases the
emphasis on reliability and speed
and it can be of great use when you have
to transfer large amounts of data
between networks
now another way this can be useful is if
it's used to add compute or storage
capacity to data centers
next we have azure dns domain name
service or azure dns can be used to host
your domains on azure
this provides high availability and
great performance
it provides fast responses to dns
queries by taking advantage of
microsoft's global network
it also provides high availability next
we have virtual network
azure virtual network allows the azure
resources to communicate with each other
or other on-premise networks via the
internet and all of this
is kept extremely secure now with this
users can create their own
private network for communication it
provides users with an
isolated and extremely secure
environment for their applications to
run
now all of the traffic stays entirely
within the azure network
and it also allows users to design their
own networks
next we have traffic manager now with
traffic manager you can route incoming
traffic to improve your performance and
availability
now one thing it provides is multiple
failover options
so if a particular situation goes wrong
there's always an option to consider to
salvage the situation
it helps reduce application run time and
enables the distribution of user traffic
across multiple locations it also helps
the people who are using it
to know where the customers connecting
from across the world
next we have load balancer with this you
are provided the ability to instantly
scale applications
at the same time providing high
availability and improved network
performance for users applications
it can be integrated into virtual
machines and cloud services
it provides highly reliable applications
it also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups
finally we have azure vpn gateway now
this allows users to connect their
on-premise networks to azure
using a site-to-site vpn now this allows
users to connect their virtual machine
to anywhere in the world through a
point-to-site vpn
and also it's very easy to manage and is
highly available
now let's talk about the storage
services first we have data lake storage
now with this what you get is a scalable
data storage with an emphasis
on cost effectiveness and scalability
now
it comes of maximum use when you
integrate it with other services
so that you can get analytics on how the
data is being used
it is also integrated with other
services like the azure blob storage
now it is also optimized for big data
analysis tools like apache spark
and hadoop next up we have blob storage
now blob storage provides a storage
capacity for data
now depending on how often a particular
data is used it is classified into
different tiers
now all the data that is within the blob
storage is unstructured data
now it has a way of ensuring that the
data integrity is maintained
every time a particular object is being
changed or the data is being accessed
and it also helps improve app
performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption
next we have queue storage now with this
you have a message queuing system
for large workloads this allows users to
build flexible applications
and separate functions not to mention
with this you can be sure
that your individual components will not
fail it also makes sure that your
application
is scalable queue storage provides queue
monitoring which helps ensure that the
customer's demands are met
then we have file stored now with file
storage you can perform
file sharing with the help of the smb
protocol or the server message block
protocol
now this data is protected by smb 3.0
and the https protocol in this case like
we mentioned in functions
azure takes care of all the hardware
needs and the operating system
deployments on its own
it also improves on-premises performance
and other capabilities
lastly we have table storage with table
storage you can deploy semi-structured
data sets
and nosql key value store now this is
used for creating applications
which have a flexible data schema and
also considering how it has a very
strong consistency model
it's mainly aimed for enterprises next
let's have a look at some web and mobile
services
first we have the azure search now with
azure search you get a cloud search
service which is powered by artificial
intelligence
with this you can develop web
applications as well as mobile
applications
now one big advantage is that you don't
have to set up or manage
your search indices azure takes care of
that and by extension
it increases your development speed the
artificial intelligence
also will provide insights and
structured information that you can use
to improve the search
and structured information next we have
logic apps
now with this you can create integration
solutions
which can connect applications that are
important to your business
now with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate
sas or software as a service
applications and enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data
within a firewall and securely connect
to services
next we have web applications now with
web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications
according to business requirements now
it supports both windows and linux
platforms
and it helps with continuous integration
or deployment abilities
another very important aspect of this is
that the data can be deployed
and hosted across multiple locations in
the world and finally we have mobile
apps with mobile apps you can create
applications for ios android and windows
platforms
one advantage is that it automatically
scales up and down
based on your requirements now in
situations where you have network issues
offline data syncing ensures that your
applications work anyway
and you can create cross-platform
applications or native applications for
ios
android and windows next let's have a
look at some container services
first let's talk about acs or azure
container services
it is also known as the azure kubernetes
services as it's a fully managed
kubernetes container orchestration
service
now what this means is that it eases the
process of container integration and
deployment
it also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your
container is kept secure next we have
container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers
now applications can be developed here
without managing virtual machines
or learning new tools all that is
azure's problem to take care of
and it enables building applications
without having to manage the
infrastructure
that is all you need to worry about is
running the container
next let's have a look at some database
services first we have the sql database
now with sql database what you get is a
relational cloud database service
now this means that it helps accelerate
your app development
and makes it easier for you to maintain
your application
now sql database is also used
extensively in migrating
workloads to the cloud and hence saves
time and cost
it also helps improve your performance
by integrating machine learning and
adaptive
technologies into your database next we
have azure cosmos db
now this is a globally distributed
multi-model database
service now what this means is that with
this
you can create application with support
nosql
it provides a high grade security system
has high availability and low latency
now this is usually used in situations
where you have a diverse and
highly unpredictable workload now let's
have a look at some security and
identity services
firstly we have the azure active
directory now if you want to know more
about azure active directory i suggest
you click on the top right corner and
watch our video
on the azure active directory this is
just an introduction
so with this you can manage user
identities
and you can make sure the resources are
kept safe with the help of
access policies most of these are
intelligence driven
now one of the main features is that you
can have access to your applications
from any location or device it helps
increase your efficiency
and helps down cutting costs when it
comes to having a help desk
it can also help improve security and
can respond to advanced threats in real
time
next you have azure active directory b2c
it helps provide customer identity
and access management in the cloud now
protecting customer identity is
extremely important
for an organization and that's what
azure adb2c does
now it also enables the application to
be scaled to
great amounts even billions of customers
next we have the azure security center
this is basically like a command post
with which you get
a complete view of the security across
users
on your on-premises and cloud workloads
so with this you are given
thread protection method that adapts to
situations and helps reduce
exposing you to threats it also has
rapid threat response
and makes the process of finding and
fixing vulnerabilities
a whole lot easier next up let's talk
about monitoring and management services
so first let's have a look at azure
advisor now azir advisor is basically
a guide for the best practices when it
comes to azure
now when you follow these it improves
performance security
cost and increases availability now it
also
learns from how you use the services on
your configuration and usage pattern
and the adjustments that it suggests can
be implemented very quickly
and easily next we have network watcher
now with this you can monitor
diagnose and understand the working of
your network
now you can monitor your network without
actually having to login to your virtual
machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern
how much traffic is coming towards you
how much you're giving and so much more
it also helps diagnose vpn problems that
you might have
with detailed logs and finally you have
the azure resource manager
now with this you can ensure that the
resources that you have
are managed and deployed at a consistent
rate
now this makes it extremely easy for you
to manage and visualize your resources
that are used in your applications or
some other requirements
and you can control who can access your
resources as well as perform
actions on it i hope you guys found this
informative and helpful
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here